نشرت صحيفه الاندبندنت تحليلا يقول ان
موقف نتنياهو بشان غزه يزيد في عزلته في
وقت تتطلع فيه الدول في جميع انحاء الشرق
الاوسط والغرب الى ما سياتي في اليوم
التالي للحرب وتابع التحليل ان الموقف
المتشدد الذي اتخذه نتنياهو في الايام
الاخيره بشان رفض انشاء دوله فلسطينيه
يعكس علنا الموقف الذي اتخذه طوال
الغالبيه الع ظمى من حياته السياسيه لكن
الرفض الصريح للسياسه الخارجيه للولايات
المتحده يكشف عن مساحه اقل للمناوره لدى
نتنياهو في مقابله مع صحيفه لوموند قال
عامي ايالون الرئيس السابق لجهاز الشباك
الاسرائيلي اذا رفضنا السلام مع
الفلسطينيين فان ما ينتظرنا سيكون اسوا
مما وقع في السابع من اكتوبر ويرى ايالون
ان الحرب في غزه لا يمكن الفوز بها ويحذر
من اندلاع انتفاضه جديده في الضفه
الغربيه قالت صحيفه تايمز اوف اسرائيل ان
210 من اعضاء الكونغرس وقعوا رساله الى
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتقدوا فيها قضيه
جنوب افريقيا في محكمه العدل الدوليه
وطالبوا بلينكن بالاستمرار في تقديم الدعم
المناسب لاسرائيل في معارضه الدعوه واتهم
الموقعون على الرساله جنوب افريقيا باساءه
استخدام العمليه القضائيه لنزع الشرعيه عن
اسرائيل قال مارون كايروز رئيس منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا في المنتدى
الاقتصادي العالمي في مقابله مع موقع
المونيتور قال ان ازمه البحر الاحمر لم
تؤثر بعد ماديا في اسواق الطاقه العالميه
لان امدادات الطاقه لم تتعطل بشكل كبير
لكنه حذر من ان الصراع اذا تصاعد وانتشر
فقد يكون له تاثير كبير وسيكون وحينها
التوقيت سيئا للغايه على العالم اذا تعرض
لصدمه طاقه ختاما نقلت مجله فورن بوليسي
عن مصادر في وزارتي الدفاع والخارجيه
الامريكيتين والبيت الابيض ان الولايات
المتحده لم تعد مهتمه بالوجود في سوريا
وراى ان هذه المهمه لم تعد ضروريه وتجري
حاليا مناقشات داخليه نشطه لتحديد كيفيه
الانسحاب وتوقيته واضافت المجله ان بعض من
في البنتاجون يقترح ترتيبا تتعاون فيه
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مع قوات النظام
السوري لمواجهه تنظيم الدوله في اطار مسار
واضح نحو الانسحاب الامريكي من
سوريا